주식시장의 가장 중요한 이벤트가 있었죠
바로 빅테크 실적 발표라는 그 이벤트가 있었는데
사실 제가 이걸 빨리 영상을 만들었어야 되는데
여행을 또 가느라고 약간 영상이 좀 늦었습니다
하지만 늦은 만큼 제 생각을 좀 잘 정리해서 만들어봤고요
빅테크 중에서도 마이크로소프트, 구글, 메타, 아마존 같은
가장 중요한 이 회사들이 실적 발표를 했기 때문에
이제 AI가 어느 방향으로 가는지 우리가 알 수가 있는데요
실적에 대한 기본적인 부분들은 여러분들이 아마
다른 영상이나 자료들을 통해서 확인을 하셨을 것 같아서
제가 바라보는 입장에서 한번 얘기를 해보겠습니다
첫 번째 제가 가장 중요하게 생각했던 것 중에 하나는
바로 캐펙스가 계속 상향이 되는가 였어요
여기서 캐펙스라는 건 여러분들도 아시다시피
얼마나 많이 데이터 센터에 돈을 때려 붓는가
라는 의미가 있는 것 같아요
다행히도 보시면 아시겠지만
진스티커에서 텔레그램에서 갖고 왔는데
결론만 말씀드리면 구글, 마이크로소프트, 메타, 아마존
전부 다 캐펙스를 더 할 것이다 라고 얘기를 했습니다
그러니까 당연히 이 AI 투자는 지속이 된다 라고 보시면 되겠죠
그래서 제가 누누이 말씀드렸지만
만약에 빅테크들의 캐펙스가 꺾인다
그때부터는 확실히 조심을 해야 될 수도 있거든요
근데 아직은 계속 상향되고 있는 것 같아요
상향되는 모습을 보여줬기 때문에
조금은 안심을 해도 되지 않을까
뭐 이런 생각을 했습니다
그리고 이번 분기에 주인공이라고 할 수 있는 회사는
아무래도 바로 구글이라고 볼 수가 있는 것 같아요
주인공의 기준은 뭐냐
아주 쉽게 말하면
각각의 클라우드 시장이 얼마나 성장하느냐
라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다
왜냐하면 오늘날의 클라우드 시장은
전통적인 클라우드가 CPU가 중심이었던 그 과거의 클라우드가
전통적인 클라우드가 실적을 이끄는 게 아니라
GPU가 중심이 된 AI 관련된 서비스를 서빙하는
AI와 관련된 서비스가 돌아가는
그 클라우드가 성장의 중심이기 때문에
오늘날 클라우드 지표가 잘 나온다라는 거는
그 회사가 AI 관련된 걸 가장 잘하고 있다
이렇게 해석할 수가 있겠죠
근데 그게 누구였다?
바로 구글이었습니다
구글이 이렇게 성장률이
전년 동기 대비해서
63%로 늘었습니다
63%나 나왔어요
그래서 너무 긍정적이고
성장이 사실 25년 만에도 잘 안 나왔는데
갑자기 성장률이 치고 올라가기 시작했다는 게
너무 긍정적인 포인트인 것 같고
이런 구글의 성장의 중심에는
엔트로픽이라는 회사
그러니까 클로드를 만드는
엔트로픽이라는 회사가 한 축에 있고
또 다른 한 축에는
구글의 재미나이 서비스 자체가
상당히 잘 되는 게 또 한 축에 있고
또 마지막 한 축은
구글은 엔비디아 GPU만의
쓰는 게 아니라
구글의 TPU를 또 서비스를 하잖아요
구글의 TPU를 기반해서
인공지능을 많은 거를 학습하고
또 추론을 할 수가 있기 때문에
이 구글 TPU의 수요까지
전부 다 녹여 있다 보니까
구글 클라우드가 다른 회사들의
클라우드에 비해서
더 잘 나가는 부분들이 있는 것 같고
또 한 가지는
구글 클라우드 자체가
사실 덩치가 제일 작아요
AWS 아마존의 클라우드가
사실 덩치가 제일 크고
그 다음이 Azure
마이크로소프트 Azure
그리고 구글 클라우드가
세 번째로 덩치가 작기 때문에
이 가속 속도가
상대적으로 기저효과가 있다 보니까
더 퍼센트는 더 커 보이는 부분도 있다라는
말씀을 드립니다
자 그리고 이 엔트로픽
요즘에 뭐 제가 엔트로픽 얘기를
되게 많이 한 거 같아요
그래서 이 엔트로픽과 관련된 얘기를
또 이 빅테크와 빅테크 실적을 얘기하면서
엔트로픽 얘기를 안 할 수가 없는데요
사실 엔트로픽은 늘 아마존 AWS가
프라이머리 클라우드라고 밝히고 있긴 합니다
무슨 말이냐면 AWS가 중전이고
후궁이 구글 클라우드다
약간 요런 느낌
그러니까 첫 번째
나의 첫 번째로 나의 짝은 AWS인데
이게 프라이머리 클라우드가 뭐 그런 의미고요
그래서 AWS도 실적이 예상보다 좋게 나온 거는 맞고
엔트로픽의 프라이머리 클라우드가
주요한 클라우드 사업자가 AWS임에도 불구하고
사실 구글이 어떻게 보면
더 수치적으로 구글이 좀 더
덕을 본 느낌이에요
그렇게 볼 수가 있겠습니다
아까도 말씀드렸지만 기저효과가 있기 때문에
구글이 애초에 매출이 작기 때문에
조금만 올라가도 더 상승폭이 커 보이는 느낌이 있고요
그리고 이제 엔트로픽이 TPU를 점점 다양하게 쓰고 있다
라는 게 시장에 어느 정도의 컨센서스인 것 같아요
그래서 클로드 오퍼스 4.5가 나왔을 때도 학습을 할 때
구글의 TPU가 주로 쓰여졌다 라고 알려져 있습니다
그래서 구글의 TPU가 점점 시장을
조금씩 조금씩 장악하는 느낌이 있어요
참고로 클로드 오퍼스는
클로드 오퍼스 4.6과 4.7도 나오긴 했는데
이 두 버전은 학습을 할 때
엔비디아 GPU를 했는지
구글 TPU가 어느 정도 기여를 했는지
이런 게 알려져 있지는 않아요
그래서 정확하게 알 수는 없는데
충분히 구글의 영향이 4.6, 4.7에도 있을 수 있지 않을까
라고 추정을 할 수가 있습니다
그러다 보니까 자연스럽게
구글이 최근에 엔트로픽에 투자를 결정을 했죠
그래서 4월 24일날 구글이 엔트로픽에 투자를 했는데
상당히 좀 흥미로웠습니다
흥미로운 부분이 있어요
뭐가 흥미롭냐
뭐 금액이 40 빌리언 달러라는
엄청나게 큰 금액이다라는 것도 흥미롭지만
자 뭐가 흥미롭냐면
구글이 처음에 투자하는 금액은
10 빌리언 달러 정도밖에 안 되는데
이제 마일스톤을 달성하면
추가로 투자를 엔트로픽에게 해주겠다라고 했거든요
근데 그 마일스톤이
그 마일스톤이 엔트로픽이
구글의 TPU 인프라를 얼마나 사용하는지예요
그러니까 다시 말하면
구글이 엔트로픽한테 투자하는데
조건이 엔트로픽이 구글의 TPU를 얼마나 많이 사용하느냐라는 겁니다
순환출자스러운 느낌이 있어
그래서 구글이 엔트로픽에게 돈을 넣는데
그 투자금으로 엔트로픽은 다시 TPU를 사용하고
그 TPU가 구글 매출로 인식이 되는데
이렇게 이 구글 매출로 인식이 된 부분이
일정 금액이 넘어가면
구글이 투자를 더한다라는 겁니다
그래서 이거 뭐 많이 봤죠
엔비디아도 약간 비슷하게 하는 부분이 있고
약간 순환출자스러운 부분들이
있기는 합니다
더 재밌는 거는
엔트로픽이 지금 양다리 중이다라는 거예요
이게 무슨 말이냐면
엔트로픽이 아마존한테 또 투자를 받았습니다
그래서 아마존이 이번에는
5빌리언 달러가
한국 돈으로 한 7조원 정도 투자를 했고
추가 투자는 20빌리언까지 더할 수 있다라고 하는데
여기서도 마일스톤 역시
AWS 사용량이다라고 합니다
구글이랑 똑같은 거죠
그래서 클라우드를 많이 사용하면
사용할수록
추가 투자를 클라우드 회사에게 더 받는
순환출자스러운 부분들이 있고
또 여기서 재밌는 것 중에 하나는
아마존의 학습용 칩을 엔트로픽이 이용을 하는데
이용하는 것뿐만 아니라
칩 설계까지도 엔트로픽과 같이 하는
더 깊이 엮이는 딜이다라는 거죠
이 엔트로픽이 상당히 재밌는 게
제가 알기로 지분율도 아마 아마존이 조금 더 많긴 할 건데
아마존과 구글 사이에서
엔트로픽은 절묘하게 줄타기를 하면서
뭐랄까
딜을 조건을 자신에게 좀 더 유리하게 끌고 가고 있다라는 게
지켜보는 입장에서 상당히 흥미로운 부분입니다
자 근데 이게 또 재밌는 게
엔트로픽이 일단 워낙 잘 나가기도 하고
또 아마존이나 구글 역시
레퍼런스가 너무 필요하잖아요
그러니까 구글도 TPU가 있고
아마존도 학습용 칩이 있는데
이 학습용 칩이건
추론형 칩이건
어쨌든 각자가 만든 AI 가속기가
엔비디아의 GPU보다 더 인정받기 위해서는
결국에는 좋은 레퍼런스가 필요하다 보니까
자 엔트로픽이 만약에 구글에 반도체 갖다 썼다?
그러면 너무나도 좋은 레퍼런스겠죠
그러다 보니까 구글과 아마존 둘 다
엔트로픽에게 강한 구애를 하는
그런 느낌이 있다라는 거 말씀드리고요
엔트로픽에
클로드가 질주를 계속하는 한
AWS와 구글의 실적이 아마 계속 잘 나올 것 같고
대충 제가 보니까
구글이 아무래도 여전히 좀 기저효과가 있다 보니까
상승폭은 더 구글이 좋을 수도 있겠다
이번 분기처럼 그런 생각이 들었습니다
자 그리고 오늘 또 중요한
이번 빅테크 실적 발표를 보면서
결국에는 빅테크의 실적 발표가
오늘날 현재 AI가 어떻게 돌아가고 있는지에 대해서
가장 설명을 드리고 싶습니다
빅테크의 실적 발표 설명을 잘해주고 있지 않겠습니까?
왜냐면 AI를 가장 잘 활용하는 회사가
바로 빅테크이기 때문인데
그래서 그들의 실적 발표를 잘 들어보면
이들이 현재 업황이 강한 그런 분야가
어딘지를 자연스럽게 알 수가 있는데요
바로 그 네 가지 분야 얘기를 좀 해 보려고 합니다
자 그러니까 어느 분야가 지금 가장 쇼티지
병목이 심하냐
가장 수요가 강하냐라고 봤을 때는
마치 아이돌계의 장카설류 같은 거
가장 중요한 이 네 가지
4세대 아이돌 중에 가장 잘 나가는
이 네 명의 여자 아이돌을 장카설류라고 부르잖아요
물론 저는 잘 모릅니다만
어쨌든 그런 장카설류 같은
AI의 네 가지 분야가 뭐냐라고 봤을 때는
메모리, 전력, 광통신, CPU인 것 같습니다
그래서 각각을 이번 빅테크 실적 발표에서
각각에 대해서
어느 정도 언급이 됐는가
플러스 저의 생각을 조금만 섞어 보면요
일단 메모리 및 저장장치 얘기를 좀 해 볼 건데
자 요즘에 메모리 뜨거운지가 한참 됐는데
뭐 그래도 한번 복습할 겸
왜 메모리가 이렇게 뜨겁냐 라고 물어보신다면
결국에 AI가 AI인 이유가 왜 그럴까요
AI가 왜 인공지능일까요
왜 지능이 있을까요 라고 생각을 해 보면
결국에 이 지능이 있으려면
자신이 할 말과 할 일을 기억할 수가 있어야 합니다
채찍 PT가 처음 나올 때만 해도
단순한 업무들에 대해서만
질문을 하고 답변을 받았기 때문에
기억할 게 그리 많지 않았는데
이제는 기억할 게 너무 많아진 거죠
그래서 지능이 생기기 위해서는 기억이 필요하고
성능이 어느 정도 좋아지면서
기억할 게 점점 많아지다 보니까
메모리에 대한 수요가 엄청나게 빠른 속도로 늘어나고 있죠
그래서 메모리의 전체 수요는
생각해보면 AI 모델이 해야 하는 기억 곱하기
사용자만큼 늘어난다 라고 보시면 돼요
왜냐하면 사용자가 늘어나도
메모리가 더 많이 필요한 거고
AI 모델이 더 많이 기억해야 해도
메모리가 더 많이 필요한 건데
지금은 이 두 가지가 전부 다 증가하는 추세다 보니까
메모리 전체의 양이 훨씬 더 많이 필요하다 라는 겁니다
아주 심플하게 설명하자면
특히나 코아2 같은 해치펀드에서도
디렘의 수요가 1인당 유저당 필요한 디렘의 수요가
향후 5년 동안 5배가 늘어날 것이다 라고 이야기를 할 정도인데
특히 이거는 AI 에이전트 때문에 오는 거고
AI 에이전트라는 게 쉽게 말하면
나 대신 내 컴퓨터를 알아서 컨트롤해주는
그런 비서 같은 직원이다 라고 생각하시면 되는데
비서 일을 하기 위해서는
내 컴퓨터에 어떤 파일이 있어야 되는데
되는지도 기억을 해야 되고
내가 들어가야 하는 사이트가 뭔지도 기억을 해야 되고
그리고 그런 상황들을 기억할 때마다
은근히 많이 이 사진을 활용을 합니다
스크린샷 같은 거를 활용을 해요
실제로 에이전트가 뒷단에서 어떻게 돌아가는지를 보면
현 상황에 대해서 스크린샷을 찍고
이걸 LLM한테 물어봐서 어떻게 해야지라고 답변을 얻는데
이렇게 스크린샷을 찍으면서 기억한다는 거 자체가
더 많은 메모리가 필요할 수밖에 없는 거겠죠
아주 단순하게 생각을 해도
그래서 이 유저당에서
가장 필요한 디렘의 수요가
이렇게 계속 늘어나고 있다 라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다
그래서 사실 아주 냉정하게 말하면
디렘의 수요가 앞으로 얼만큼 더 필요한지
알고 있는 사람은 전 아무도 없다고 생각을 하고요
다만 이 에이전트라는 게 생겨나면서
논리적으로 디렘의 수요가 더 증가할 만한 상황이 됐고
메모리와 관련된 투자를 하신다면
이 에이전트가 얼마나 더 활성화가 되는지를
계속 같이 지켜봐야 할 것이다
라고 말씀을 드리고 싶습니다
자 그래서 빅테크가
이번에 실적 발표에서
메모리 관련된 코멘트가 어떤 게 있었는지를 말씀을 드리자면
마이크로소프트 같은 경우는
이번에 2026년에 190빌리언 달러 정도를
데이터 센터를 위해서 쓰겠다 라고 얘기를 했는데
그 중에 약 25빌리언 달러가 부품 가격
특히 메모리 때문에 올랐다
우리가 올해 캐펙스를 많이 하는 이유는
메모리 가격이 올라서 그런 거야 라고
아주
명확하게 이야기를
특히 25빌리언 달러가 메모리 영향이다 라고 얘기를 했는데
자 다시 말하면 그 얘기가
캐펙스가 증가한 부분 중에서
메모리의 비중이 무려 35%나 되는
아주 어마어마한 부분이 아닌가
이런 생각이 들었고요
자 메타에서도 같은 얘기를 했습니다
자 이번에 인프라를 더 짓기 위해서
캐펙스를 더 투여하기 위해서
가이던스를 상향을 했는데
그런 부분에 대부분은 부품 비용이 올라가서
특히 메모리 가격 때문이다 라고 직접 언급을 했습니다
그래서 이거는 CFO도 또 메모리 가격 급등하고 있다라는 이야기를 했고요
역시 캐펙스 가이던스 메타도 늘렸고요
그리고 아마존도 메모리 스토리지 부품 비용이 치솟았고
수요 대비 캐파가 부족한 상황이다 라고 얘기를 했고
아예 AK 공시에 공시에 아예
자 우리의 리스크는 메모리 가격입니다
자 우리의 리스크는 메모리 가격입니다. 메모리 공급에 비해
변동성입니다 라고 명시적으로 추가를 했습니다
자 그리고 알파벳은 유일하게 메모리를 대놓고 언급을 안 했고
다만 2027년은 2026년 대비
Significantly increase 그러니까 의미 있게 증가할 거다
이런 식으로 이야기를 했는데
어쨌든 많이 증가한다는 얘기인 것 같아요
그리고 컴퓨트가 좀 제약이 있다
컴퓨팅 자체의 자원의 제약이 있다
이런 표현들을 했는데
유일하게 메모리를 대놓고 언급을 했습니다
그럼에도 불구하고 빅테크 4개 중에 빅테크 3곳이
메모리가 너무 비싸서 문제다 라고 얘기를 하고 있다라는 것 자체는
현재 메모리의 인기 메모리의 수요는 이상이 없다 라고 봐도 무방한 것 같습니다
자 그리고 전력과 관련된 거 또 어떤지 한번 보면은
마이크로소프트 여전히 전력이 또 가장 제약 요인이다
이렇게 얘기를 했어요
그래서 컴퓨팅이 문제가 아니라
전력이 없다
우리 전기가 없어서 못 하고 있다
이런 얘기를 마이크로소프트는 했고요
다만 이제 다른 빅테크들은 전력 얘기를 대놓고 하지는 않았어요
약간 돌려서는 얘기했다고 볼 수 있는데
다만 그럼에도 불구하고 어쨌든 전력 쪽은 여전히 업황이 매우 좋은 것으로 보입니다
한국에서도 변압기 회사들
뭐 효성중고급이나 현대 일렉트릭 이런 회사들 계속 많이 오르고 있죠
뭐 그렇고 블룸에너지도 다시 신고가를 뚫었으니까
이런 부분들이 계속 이제 전력 부분이 계속 올라가고 있습니다
에너지 부분이 계속 병목이다라는 것들을 볼 수가 있는 것 같고요
그리고 CPU
요즘 새롭게 AI 테마로 떠오르고 있는 CPU도 살짝 보면
CPU에 대해서도 사실 인텔이 CPU가 앞으로 정말 잘 팔릴 거애로
라고 얘기하는 것보다
인텔에게서부터 CPU를 사야하는 빅테크가
CPU가 진짜 중요하다고 얘기하면 진짜 의미가 있는 거겠죠
인텔 입장에서는 자기 회사를 좀 더 올려치기를 해야하는
그런 욕망이 있을 수 있죠
인텔 입장에서는 자기 회사를 좀 더 올려치기를 해야하는 그런 욕망이 있을 수 있죠
이런 제3자 이런 빅테크가 어떤 얘기를 하는지가 중요한데
역시나 CPU가 중요하다는 얘기가 이번 실적 발표에서 나왔습니다
그래서 아마존 같은 경우는 CPU를 핵심 자산으로 적극적으로 어필을 했고요
마이크로소프트도 캐펙스의 절반이 CPU와 GPU 중심으로 이루어질 것이다
라고 얘기를 했어요
그래서 GPU 뿐만 아니라 CPU까지 같은 어떤 병목이다라는 식의 표현이 있어요
CPU도 이제 확실히 중요해진 건 맞는 것 같고요
그리고 CPU 같은 경우는 당장 Q를 늘릴 수가 없습니다
왜냐하면 어차피 또 CPU도 만들 수 있는 캡파를 그렇게 함부로 못 늘리고
그 캡파조차 다 TSMC 코어스 쪽에 다 가 있어가지고
그거를 더 많이 받아내는 게 지금 쉬운 상황이 아니거든요
그래서 CPU는 당분간 Q 증가는 없을 거고
P 증가로만 아마 실적에 반영이 될 것 같은데
어떻게 보면 CPU의 이 병목이 더 길어질 수도 있는 부분이 아닐까
이런 생각이 들었어요
왜냐하면 Q가 어쨌든 당장 구조적으로 못 늘어나는 상황이기 때문에
그러면 CPU의 이 쇼티지 사이클이 더 오래 갈 수도 있는 거 아닌가
라는 생각이 들었습니다
다만 CPU가 조금 아쉬운 건
이미 CPU와 관련된 회사들의 시가총액이 너무나도 크다라는 거
요게 조금은 아쉬운 부분이겠죠
그리고 광통신 얘기도 살짝 해보겠습니다
상대적으로 막 대놓고 언급되진 않았는데
그럼에도 불구하고 계속 스케일업을 한다거나
아니면 데이터 센터끼리 연결을 한다거나
이런 표현들
그래서 내부적으로 더 많은 GPU들이 더 많이 만들어질 거고
그 GPU들 사이에서 더 많은 연결이 있을 것이다
라는 그런 암시가 꾸준히 이어졌다 정도로 볼 수가 있을 것 같습니다
광통신 아주 짧게만 설명해 보면
결국에 GPU와 GPU가 연결되고
연결이 돼야 되는 건데
과거에는 이게 구리로 연결이 됐는데
이게 스피드를 높이려고 하다 보니까
이제 구리가 아니라 광으로 연결이 되는 거고
그리고 GPU가 늘어나면 늘어날수록
이 연결은 N제곱으로 늘어나거든요
그러니까 GPU의 절대 개수가 10배가 늘어나면
이 연결은 N제곱 100배가 늘어나야 되는 거다 보니까
이 연결한 건 결국에 NC2니까
예전에 우리 배웠던 확률과 통계를 생각해보면
이제 N컴비네이션2니까
그만큼 늘어나니까
이제 제곱의 방향으로 늘어난다는 거
기억을 해 주시면 좋을 것 같고
그러다 보니까 이제 그중에서도 가장 광 인프라에서 비싼 거는
광 트랜시버라는 광신호를 변환해 주는 어떤 장치인데
요게 이제 광 인프라에서 가장 비용 기준으로 가장 비중이 큰데
이 광 트랜시버에서도 가장 EML 레이저 칩의 가격 비중이 가장 크다 보니까
그거를 만드는 루멘트 칩이 가장 비중이 크다 보니까
자 그래서 4가지 정도 제가 짧게 말씀드렸는데
이 4가지 테마를 봤을 때는 기본적으로 큰 이상이 없어 보이고
한 가지 정도 제가 최근에 흥미롭게 보는 거는 전력 반도체이긴 합니다
근데 이거 잘 모르겠어요 아직 조금씩 보고 있는데
약간 납득이 되긴 하는데
이게 다크호스처럼 우리 그 장카설류 말고도
다크호스인 아이돌들이 있지 않겠습니까
약간 그런 느낌으로 전력 반도체도 약간 납득이 되긴 하는데
AI 쪽에서는 다크호스로 보인다라는 말씀을 드리고
이건 제가 조금 더 스터디가 되면 말씀을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
그리고 마지막으로 당부의 이야기를 드리면
사실 2025년 하반기부터 AI는 계속 좋았거든요.
그래서 세부 지표, 제가 팔로우하고 있는 지표들을 봤을 때
세부 지표가 꺾인 적은 없음에도 불구하고
주가, 그러니까 어떻게 보면 시장의 믿음이죠.
시장 참여자들의 AI에 대한 믿음은
이런 세부 지표와는 상관없이
중간중간에 여러 가지 이유를 들면서 멈췄었습니다.
AI 회사들의 실적은 흔들리지 않지만
우리의 마음은 흔들렸다.
그래서 앞으로도 AI 쪽은 당장 테마가 죽거나 할 것 같지는 않은데
이 사이사이에 많은 변동성들, 특히 내려가는 변동성들
충분히 있을 수 있을 것 같다는 말씀을 드리고 싶고
이제는 호르무즈 자체를 시장에서 그렇게 안 좋게
보는 건 아니니까
호르무즈와 관련된 걸 갖고
당장 1차원적으로 문제를 삼지는 않겠지만
이제는 인플레이션 관련된 지표가
뭔가 이상이 생기기 시작하면
그것에 대해서 시장이 안 좋게 반응할 수도 있지 않을까
안 좋게 반응할 수도 있다는 점들을 우리가 기억을 하면서
시장을 조금 더 보수적으로 바라봤으면 좋겠고요.
그리고 마지막으로 조금 더 말씀을 드리면
제가 이거 얼마 전에 머니코믹스 나와서도 말씀을 드렸었고
제 유튜브에서도 예전에 말씀을 드렸는데
AI 투자자들에게는
투자할 때 완벽한 지표는 없지만
그래도 AI가 잘 되는지 궁금할 때는
이 두 가지를 보면 간접적으로 알 수 있다고 생각합니다.
하나는 오픈 라우터라는 곳에서 측정을 하는
어떤 모델들이 토큰을 얼만큼 소비하는가
그러니까 토큰을 소비한다는 건
쉽게 말하면 AI를 많이 쓰고 있다는 거거든요.
AI가 점점 많이 쓰고 있어지냐
이거죠. 주마다 측정을 하기 때문에
얼마나 AI를 많이 쓰고 있는지를
이렇게 간접적으로 우리가 볼 수가 있습니다.
보면 그래도 우상향 하는 것들은
그것처럼 확실히 확연히 보이죠.
이게 1년 전이랑 비교하면 거의 10배가 증가했더라고요.
그리고 또 하나는 GPU가 얼마나 사람들이 많이 쓰는지
근데 이 숫자가 이 선이 아래로 가면 갈수록
GPU가 인기가 많다라는 건데
최근에 보시면 이 선이 다 아래로 내려와 있죠.
그러니까 이 GPU에 대한 인기가 엄청나다.
그래서 GPU에 대한 인기가 많다는 건
사람들이 AI를 많이 쓴다라는 거기 때문에
안심을 많이 하죠.
안심을 해도 지금 보이는 그런 지표들로 봐서는
안심을 해도 되는 것 같다라는 말씀을 드리고요.
그래서 AI 자체는 이상 없다.
근데 우리의 마음은 AI에 대한 우리의 믿음은
이상이 있을 수 있다라는 말씀을 드리고
어디서 우리가 이거를 참고해야 하는지에 대해서는
링크를 제가 설명란 고정 댓글에 써두겠습니다.
참고로 이 자료는 314 리서치에서 발간을 하는 건데
월 단위로 발간을 하는 것 같더라고요.
그래서 제가 그냥 314 리서치 X 링크를 드릴 테니까
그냥 그거를 보면은 한 달에 한 번씩 나올 겁니다.
그래서 이거는 그냥 이 회사의 X 주소를 알려드리는 걸로 할게요.
그럼 저는 또 돌아오도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.